[تصفيق]
على وقع مواجهات بخموت اطول المعارك
واشدها منذ اندلاع الحرب على اوكرانيا قبل
عام ونيف تكشفت اكثر حقيقه الخلافات بين
الولايات المتحده والقياده الاوكرانيه
فنقلا عن مسؤولين في اداره بايدن قالت
صحيفه بوليتيكولا الامريكيه ان كيف تجاهلت
نصائح واشنطن العسكريه وان الخلاف بين
العاصمتين يتصاعد في الكواليس بشان اهداف
الحرب وكيفيه وموعد نهايه الصراع العسكري
مع روسيا كما لا يبدي الجانب الامريكي
رضاه عن مجريات معركه باخموت ويعتبرها
استنزافا لا اكثر من اجل مدينه غير مهمه
من الناحيه الاستراتيجيه
ووفق الصحيفه فان تخريب خط انابيب نورد
ستريم بات من عوامل التوتر الجديده ايضا
بعد توصل المخابرات الامريكيه الى استنتاج
مفاده ان مجموعه مؤيده لاوكرانيا كانت
مسؤوله عن الحادث ويضاف الى ذلك رفض
واشنطن خطط كييف لاستعاده شبه جزيره القرم
التي ترسخ فيها الوجود الروسي منذ نحو عشر
سنوات
وتعكس هذه التسريبات ارتدادات الحرب على
كل الاطراف بعد عام من اندلاعها وهي اذ
تتزامن مع تقدم
ميدانير وسيطرتها على اجزاء واسعه من
بخموت فقد تعني مزيدا من المصاعب للجانب
الاوكراني ميدانيا وسياسيا ذلك ما قد يفسر
مصارعه وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه الى اصدار
بيان يشرح اهميه الدفاع عن بخموت مخاطبا
الامريكيين ضمنا اعتبر البيان ان القوات
الروسيه تعزز عملياتها في المنطقه للوصول
الى الحدود الاداريه لمنطقتي
وان المقاومه الاوكرانيه وفق البيان هدفها
تكبيد الروس خسائر كبيره وافقادهم
امكاناتهم الهجوميه وقدراتهم على التقدم
في اتجاهات اخرى
ايا يكن الامر فقد سبق لمسؤولين امريكيين
ان ابدو تحفظات على اندفاع اوكرانيا وسقف
تطلعاتها العالي فوزير الدفاع لويد اوستن
اعتبرت دفاعا بخموت مجرد عمل رمزي اكثر من
كونه قيمه استراتيجيه كما اعرب البنتاغون
باستمرار عن شكوكه فيما اذا كان الجيش
الاوكراني قادرا على دفع القوات الروسيه
الى خارج الحدود ناهيك عن استعاده شبه
جزيره القرم